this simultaneous meeting of weber
district council cabinet and mid Suffolk
District Council cabinet may I first of
all remind you of some domestic
arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use please do not interrupt other
speakers if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave please remember to use the chat
function only to indicate that you wish
to speak and not to post comments or
questions please note the messages in
the chat panel can be viewed by people
watching the live broadcast I would like
to remind everyone present that this
meeting will be broadcast live to the
Internet and will be capable of repeated
viewing the whole of the meeting will be
filmed except where there are
confidential or exempt items if you make
a representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being filmed by entering
this meeting as a speaker you're also
consenting to being recorded by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and/or training purposes the
council members of the public and the
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
[Music]
I'm now going to introduce okay Claire
you're going to do the introductions yes
so as well as the cabinet members
present we also have counselor Lavinia
Hanna heading him Rachel ebon councillor
Keith Welham councillor John field
councillor Alice democra and councillor
penny Orton and we also have our chief
executive officer of onea a monitoring
officer Emily you'll myself
the committee clerk Claire Philpott and
joining us will be Paul Bryant the
neighbourhood planning and currently we
have the Assistant Director for custom
serve
- Sara Wilcock Thank You chair thank you
before I move to the agenda move to the
agenda please note the time varying the
order of the mid Suffolk agenda so the
item - apologies for absence and
substitutions and item 3 declarations of
interest are taken before the first
substantive item so apologies for
absence and substitutions from mid
Suffolk members I will now ask the
governance officer to roll call for the
members present Thank You chair when I
call your name if you could just
indicate your presence by either saying
present oh yes
so counselor Gerard Brewster take it
burn counselor do d-flat man present
counsel is Jessica Fleming present -
gold present councillor Suzie Morley
present councillor Harry Richardson we
have received apologies for and can't
head
yes present thank you next item is to
receive declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interest by mid Suffolk
members are there any to declare okay so
we're now moving to the first
substantive item for mid Suffolk
so this is reference MC a slash 19 / 59
the drink stone neighborhood plan this
item is for mid Suffolk only therefore
only mid Suffolk cabinet members will be
able to debate anthem
I will now invite the cabinet member for
planning councillor David Byrne to
introduce the report
councillor Bern sorry muted microphone
as usual always catches me out I got my
paper up ready to read but he couldn't
hear a word um good morning thank you
sure and good morning councillors the
report you have before you updates
cabinet on the drink stone neighborhood
plan more specifically it sets out two
recommendations first is that the
planning that the parish counts will be
instructed to modify their plan in
accordance with the independent
examiner's recommendations and secondly
that subject to satisfactory completion
of that task it seeks approval for this
plan to be advanced to a local
referendum the drink stone neighborhood
plan follows a tried and tested formula
it contains 13 policies covering housing
the natural environment design
infrastructure and services and it
provides for a level of growth
consistent with the emerging joint local
plan while seeking to protect and
preserve what is important to local
residents paragraph 4.2 of the report
sets out the key stages prior to
examination the egg self is discussed in
paragraphs 4.3 to 4.5 and while not
every modification is listed here
members should note that over the 13
policies the examiner only felt it
necessary to make very minor
modifications to five of them at
paragraph 4.8 you will see confirmation
that our officers have looked at those
modifications are and are in agreement
that all should be made
anticipating this would be the case I
can confirm today that the Parish
Council have modified their plan as
required and have therefore already
complied with the first recommendation
consequently it only remains for us to
agree that this plan be advanced to a
local referendum covering the parish of
drink stone now we are all aware of how
coronavirus has changed the way we
conduct our business operations and
daily lives neighbourhood planning has
not been immune from this but in drink
stones case it was fortunate that the
examiner was able to undertake her site
visit before lockdown measures were
introduced and that the examination was
able to proceed as normal
previously the transition period from
receipt of examiner's report to our
setting a date for and holding the local
referendum typically takes a couple of
months in paragraph four point 12 your
attention is drawn to the postponement
of elections and referendums regulations
which came into effect on the 7th of
April this year these now mean that the
earliest date that any referendum on the
drink stone neighborhood plan could
conceivably take place is the 6th of May
2021 Horst and the government will be
keeping these regulations under review
it is understandable that any group who
has got this far might feel frustrated
at having to wait a whole year before
their plan can be put to the local votes
government have therefore provided
clarity through a further clarity
through an update to planning practice
guidance which states that where a local
planning authority has issued a decision
statement detail its intention to send a
neighbourhood plan to referendum that
plan can be given significant weight in
decision-making so far as the planners
material to the application
we've always we have always issued such
decision statements but officers have
taken this opportunity to see what other
local planning authorities are doing and
to refresh our statement so that it is
relevant and clear in content and
intention I am also assured that our
officers will continue to monitor all
guidance so far as it pertains to this
plan and we'll take whatever steps and
actions are necessary and appropriate
and therefore commend this plan to you
and ask cabinet to agree that we
advanced to a local referendum whenever
that might be so I therefore propose the
recommendations and I seek a second to
thank you would somebody like second I'm
Jarrett Brewster I'm very happy to say
councilor burns proposal madam chair
thank you thank you very much councillor
Brewster we're now going to move on to
questions from mid Suffolk members so
I'll go through each of your names in
turn and then we'll move to questions
from anybody else in the room councillor
Brewster do you have any questions I
don't have any questions on this madam
chair Thank You councillor burn no I
don't manage em councillor flapman no
thank you chair
councillor Fleming no questions Thank
You councillor Galt no questions just
congratulations to all involved in
preparing to plan thank you
Thank You councillor gold councillor
white hit no questions okay I'm
I'm now going to ask the ward member to
say councilor rotten Thank You chairman
I mean as you can see by the report in
front of you drinks in is a small
village in comparison to a lot of the
others first in Elms well warp etc and
they have put an enormous amount of work
into preparing their neighborhood plan
they've had several public meetings so I
really hope members have been able to
read through the actual plan itself
because it does include of the highest
level of environmental issues and I
believe could be used as an exemplar for
others in the pipeline I see from the
recommendations from the inspector to
actually extend the drinks and green
settlement boundary and I'm pleased that
that's been agreed by the parish council
I was very interested to hear from
councilor burn about obviously the
problem about going forward for
referendum and I know they will
obviously be very frustrated that they
have now got to wait until the six of
May I'm surprised that that that we
could not have had some degree of
guidance about how that could have been
done by alternative measures but at
least if I'm right then at least the
neighbourhood plan if agreed today by
your committee can be taken into account
in any future planning applications so
I'm very pleased to see the
recommendation thank you chairman Thank
You councillor rotten I'm now going to
move to questions from other members non
cabinet members council reburn would you
like to ask a question
thank you very much chair and firstly
can I just second council rottens
comments I spoke to someone in drinks in
a in a
capacity as it were several years ago
and they said was it worth us doing a
neighbor plan and I said if you want
some housing for young people or whoever
is needed in your village and there are
elements that you want to enhance in
your locality then then go for it so I'm
really pleased to see this and I'd agree
with counsel rotten that some of the
environmental aspects are really
excellent and that that probably should
be I don't know if the council the
district councillors at work and do
something to to bring those out and
highlight them to other other
communities and secondly could the
statement that counts the berm made with
regards to what happens between this
cabinet hopefully approving this and
then an actual referendum being held
could those comments and the guidance be
put somewhere or circulated somehow both
to members and to the wider wider
communities so that those that doing
neighborhood plans I'm sure they know
about it from the officer who's looking
after these but just to put other
people's minds at rest and on how these
are taken forward but so could those
comments
somehow were they on the website or or
however be circulated more widely thank
you very much chair they've councillor
burn yes thank you come sir even then we
will aim to do that we do have Paul
Bryant with us I don't know whether Paul
has anything that he'd like to add to
what some what's been asked and
discussed this morning Paul can I ask
you whether whether you'd like to say a
word or two oh yes I'll quickly say that
obviously the crowd a virus impact has
been difficult for all sorts of people
all sorts of reasons my congratulations
also to drink Stone parish council for
bringing this neighbor plan forward and
my thanks also Samina we were very for
so in the report that she was able to do
a site visit before lockdown was
introduced that meant that the
examination could carry on as normal
I've made a note of the point about
circulating the guidance more widely and
I will see if we can do something about
that so thank you for that suggestion
and I've noted also the references to
the environmental aspects of the drink
stone plan we do always encourage all
that neighbor planning groups to look
what others have done and talk to other
groups you know look at other plans and
find out what's particularly interest to
them and we will reinforce that message
as well so thank you also for that
suggestion thank you very much for that
I think thank you Paul
penny sorry counselor autumn I believe
you wish to ask a question um excuse me
um yes I mean um to put this on hold now
for a whole year
can I just I would assume then if the
government guidelines change then we
could do this much earlier if if for
example the severe guidelines do alter
then presumably we could bring this
forward um yes that would certainly be
our attention intention counselor often
I'm sure Paul would a great call would
you just like to come yes I mean at the
moment government guidance is that no no
referendums could take place until the
6th of May 2021 at the earliest as
stated in in the port and as councillor
Byrne has already mentioned you know
should that guidance change and that
date be brought forward then we will
love to bring the referendums forward
it's not just for drink stone I will be
in the same position
and potentially other neighbor plans
that are coming through the system they
may find themselves albeit that they'll
come through to cabinet later in the
year they might still be in the same
same boat and have to wait not quite so
long as doing stone and I but you know
we'll have to see how regulations change
and we will respond accordingly thank
you very much
does any other anybody else have a
question then I'm going to move on to
debate I'll now open up the item for
debate from cabinet members so again
I'll go through each of your names again
in order if you wish to say anything
councillor Brewster if you can unmute
this indeed I'd also like to offer the
congratulations to drink stone as cancer
rot instead it is a very small parish
council and small parish and I think
they've done really really well to to
get and achieve what what they are
achieving so yes that's that's just
really my comment madam chair Thank You
councillor Brewster Caliburn um no I
don't think of anything to add I die to
commend drinks don't parish council for
for this work and I I agree with counsel
Orton that it should be considered its
it is it is of a very high quality
despite the small size of the parish and
I'm happy to promote it as an exemplar
to any groups any parishes that are
considering
preparing a plan especially small ones
thanks for clapping no just just to add
many congratulations and as a ward
member for three tiny villages working
on plans
I know how much work they've put into
this so well done everybody concerned
Thank You councillor gold you might need
to unmute thank you Jeff yes I had
difficulty I'm using net yeah just eye
the eye neighborhood plan is in the
session between examination and
referendum by way of comfort there's
clear evidence that the neighborhood
plan despite not having been for the
referendum is is highly material in
determining planning matters and we've
got a planning inspector of a very
substantial appeal recognizing and going
with as it were the the neighborhood
plan and two more local decisions also
recognizing to make taking cognizance of
the of the neighborhood plan so the
signs are all there that of those not
being through a referendum the drinks
Templin will be regarded as highly
highly material and and I just must
mention the cover of the plan which is a
which is terrific and different to those
that we see but would advise against
building the skatepark as drawn on the
those that have seen it will know what I
mean meet health and safety standards
and congratulations to those who say
anything
Thank You councillor Gould and yes I
would I would also like to add my
congratulations to drink stand they're
really tiny parish with limited
resources but it's amazing what can be
achieved with lots of passion energy and
enthusiasm so I'm very happy to promote
this is an exemplar council whitehead
nothing further and to say I totally
agree with the comments for yourself
caliber and Calthrop and regarding the
plan lovely thank you very much council
whited I will now ask the governance
officer to conduct the roll call vote
Thank You chair so when I call your name
if you could just say four against or
abstain counter for councillor David
Byrne for councillor Julie Flatman for
councillor Jessica Fleming for
councillor Peter Gould for councillor
Susie Morley for and counselor John
Whitehead for thank you that's unanimous
chair thank you very much
I'm now going to hand over to the leader
of Baber district council counselor John
Ward for the first item on the Baber
agenda can I just say thank you German
and I will now leave the meeting thank
you very much councillor rotten for your
attendance and your support Thank You
councillor Morley this is for baby
members only this is the Baber agenda
item one apologies for absence I don't
believe we have have any but I'll now
ask the governess officer to roll call
for the members present from Weber
district council okay thank you chair
okay so councillor Clive Alfie present
councillor Dave Busby yeah Derrick Davis
yeah
councillor Michael Holt you know
counselor Elizabeth male VC yeah
councillor channel here councillor
Deepak are present councillor John Ward
present thank you thank you
I will now move on to baby council item
2 to receive declarations of pecuniary
and non-pecuniary interest by members
are there any to declare
how I was born yeah Thank You mr.
chairman I'd like to do Curie for paper
BC a 1950 item 3.1 sand Peter's Church
but it's non-pecuniary Thank You
counselor
yeah chair if I may please Castle Parker
yes sorry
Thank You Chancellor right no problems
yeah I will also chair declare a local
number canary in the same item BC a 1950
by virtue of the fact that there is an
item being discussed at near I was
formerly a parish counselor at Newton
and was party to the original bid
application I'm also a trustee of Newton
green trust who owned land on which any
play equipment gained by the award would
be placed and as such I'd like to remain
and comment as Ward member but I will
remove myself from the vote on this item
jet Thank You councillor Parker if there
are no other declarations then we'll
move on to the next item on our pass
back to Council Morley Thank You
councillor Ward so this is mid Suffolk
item MCA / 1960 confirmation of the
minutes of the meeting of the mid
Suffolk cabinet meeting held on the 4th
of May 20 2003 points regarding the
accuracy
No thank you can I have a proposer
please councillor Julie Flatman happy to
propose the minutes chair Thank You
councillor Flatman and do I have a
seconder
yes and councillor Jessica Fleming I'm
happy to second Thank You councillor
Fleming the governance officer will now
take a roll call vote okay once again if
you could say four against or abstain
councillor Jared Brewster for councillor
David Byrn Oh
councillor Dooley Flatman for councillor
Jessica Fleming for councillor Peter
Gould for councillor Susie morning
councillor John Whitehead for thank you
that's unanimous
thank you clear the minutes of meeting
are being confirmed and they'll be
signed at the next practical bull
opportunity are now going to hand back
to counselor John Ward for the paper
item thank you
councillor Ward you might be muted
you're dead right paper item three paper
BCA 1948 confirmation of the minutes of
meeting over Baber cabinet held on the
4th of May 2020 there any points
regarding the accuracy of the minutes
please
if not then mayor have a proposer please
cancel malvasia I'll propose thank you
seconder our seconds on council hope
Thank You council hope right
the government's officer will now take a
roll call vote Thank You councillor
Clive our fee for councillor Dave Busby
or counselor Derrick Davis what
councillor Michael Holt counsellor
Elizabeth mouths easy for Dan Osborne
for councillor Lee Parker for and count
war Thank You chair that's unanimous
right on that pass back to Council and
Morley for the next item Thank You
councillor Ward the the minutes of the
Baber meeting previous minutes have been
confirmed and they will be signed by
councillor Ward and the next practical
opportunity we're now moving to mid
Suffolk item number five which is also
Baber council item number four to
receive notifications in of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme nom received chair thank you
mid Suffolk item six and Baber item 5 is
questions by councillors we have
received five questions it's a date
can I just ask the councillor submitting
the question to written and then I asked
the cabinet member to respond so first I
first question was counselor a burn to
counselor phlegm thankfully
most chair cancer Rachael e Byrne
speaking firstly with regards the
overall performance of the council now
these these questions are relating to
item 9 on a mid Suffolk agenda which is
the quarter for outcome performance
reporting and I appreciate I only got
these questions in yesterday morning
with not with my usual week's noticed so
if I'm not able to receive fullness
responses hopefully I'll be able to
receive them in writing in due course so
firstly with regards to the overall
performance of the council why are there
still no performance measures in place
relating to the climate emergency
despite it being declared nearly a year
ago in july 2019 thank you
Thank You councillor Byrne councillor
Fleming is um thank you for your
question counselor ebin and it's it's a
pertinent question as you know the
climate change task force met four times
before the covered pretty much closed
down our work we have recently resumed
and are putting together our proposals
which would be brought to cabinet and
without disclosing the nature of these
proposals I think I can confirm that
it's very likely climate change and
environment measures will be part of our
performance assessment at mid Suffolk
exactly how and what is you know being
worked on but I think the answer is yes
if that helps if you have a follow-up
question I'd be heard glad to receive it
council heben Thank You chair Thank You
councillor Fleming for that response
I've just had hoped that there would be
something with regards to how much we're
expecting given that there are only ten
twenty thirty that we would have had
something up front in terms of the
overall percentage of emissions that we
would you know how will we because we've
got to get to zero by 2030 so in terms
of even just a an item within the
performance reporting saying percent
whatever so that and three benissa is
this a question yes who's not for debate
so why is there not a simple percentage
tin that to the performance reporting in
the first instance Thank You chair well
first off we haven't decided what the
performance measures will be and this
will be subject to discussion within the
task force and and obviously agreement
with officers so I think the answer is
we're not ready to put any definitive
proposals forward at this time
but those these will be coming forward
in the next few months thank you very
much to councillor Fleming would you
like me to continue to my second
question question yes thank you can't
win for councillor Burton thank you very
much with regards to planning
performance we have performance targets
in place but they're to do with meeting
national targets
that's GSP 0-1 and Gao however our local
communities were more concerned with
actually what happens in their backyard
so what local targets does the
administration have in place to give the
public confidence in the planning system
for their own communities thank you
Thank You councillor burn yes think
thank you thank you for the question
council Riva the development mothers
plan set out objectives for 2019 2020
and that includes rolled forward
objectives for 2021 the service plan is
accompanied by a series of
transformation activities to lead the
evolution of development management you
know I have a lengthy link there which
I'm not going to read out but we can
make it available somehow and but it's a
PDF on on the development management
service plan now working with our
customers is described on page 15 of the
plan paragraphs 8.1 to 8.5
and this includes description of our
work with part of our business community
through our client side panel working
with our communities is described on
page 17 of the plan paragraphs 10.1 to
ten point three the service plan
describes key performance measures for
good customer service in relation to our
pre-application advice service page 20
and in relation to our communities page
21 including making sure that our
communities in made aware of development
proposals and have been invited to
comment making those comments available
online in good time and helping our
parish councils understand the reasons
for our decisions the measures of the
service plan cascade into and are
tailored to individuals roles for the
purposes of staff performance objectives
the forward key performance measures for
the forward key performance measures for
twenty twenty twenty-one are detailed on
page twenty two to twenty four the
objectives in the service plan are based
on measurable outcomes which are focused
on ensuring that we communicate
effectively with our communities as
represented by both parishes applicants
and businesses I consider that public
confidence is promoted by effective
communication recognizing that local
opinion about planning merits which may
well be antagonistic case by case cannot
be considered a reliable objective
indicator of public confidence in the
planning system given the business
interruption of covered 19 we have not
reviewed outcomes as yet but these will
inform appraisals later in the year we
have also prioritized our parish survey
around kovat nineteen related
circumstances and that was launched last
week this survey work does not
pick up on the key performance measure
related to communities and we expect to
undertake that separately later in the
year is that help and thank you very
much for your comprehensive response
counselor Byrne I'm not sure that it
fully answers my question
with regards to because I think the
public often think that we only are
following government targets and not not
our own with regards to to planning but
I will look at those documents and
hopefully come back to you with a
further question in due course thank you
very much
chair would you like me to go to the
next question yes - please counselor
ebin thank you thank you very much my
next question is regards to housing
benefit in universal credit claims at TS
0 1 and O 2 for month's report we report
on kind of percentages of days when we
meet new claims and when we process
claims and so on
but there aren't performance reports
specifically relating to the numbers of
new claims so my question is what is the
increase in the number of new claims
this year against last year and given
that we should have socio-economic
policies in place to impact these how is
that working given the sharp rise in
rent arrears which was noted in report
relating to those on universal credit
what's the forecast and what has being
done to reduce it thank you very much
chair Thank You councillor burn
counselor clapping Thank You councillor
burn from the start of the financial
year 20 1920 until the end of quarter
four we saw an increase in the
percentage areas held by households in
receipt of universal credit rise credit
rise from twenty nine point thirty seven
percent to thirty six point 98 percent
this equates to arise from a hundred and
twelve thousand nine hundred and forty
to one hundred and forty six thousand
seven hundred and one
we anticipate
hey that caught one of 20-20-20 one will
show a further rise we do not currently
recall the total number of UC claimants
living in council-owned accommodation
only the number that shows arrears on
their accounts in quarter one 20 19 20
this was this was this was 109 in
quarter 3 it has risen to 136 and in
June 2020 came to 173 I'm not sure that
the council socio economic policies have
had a significant impact on the number
of claimants we're not quite sure which
socio-economic policies you're referring
to rather it is the result of the
ongoing transition of benefit claimants
from legacy benefits to universal credit
coupled with the impact of the
coronavirus and the associated lockdown
which has affected job security and
household incomes we have done some
modeling on potential rent loss over the
first few weeks and months of this
financial year but we should have a
clearer idea of the direction of travel
once quarter one figures are completed
in early July the amount of arrears held
by UC claimants will undoubtedly rise
given the number of new claims and the
lead-in period for the first payments we
were also affected by the DWP's decision
to temporarily suspend third-party
deductions for a period during the
lockdown this affected 82 meets Suffolk
tenants and we estimated an increase in
arrears of approximately proximately
3900 from this decision alone the new
income management policy has been in
place for several months and the
initiatives contained within it such as
the pre count
pre court panels have proved to be very
effective in tackling higher arrears
cases income officers are also making
contact with all new tenants to set up a
positive rent paying culture from the
start of a tenancy and we are piloting
new rent arrears letters this year to
improve customer contact and repayment
rates as a result of the corona virus
pandemic we did bring additional
resources into the income income team to
help with the increasing numbers of
tenants falling into arrears however as
we are now moving into the recovery
stage these extra staff members are no
longer available we are therefore
actively reviewing workloads and
considering how best distraction the
team in the future to meet the new
challenges as part of this work we will
be trailing rent cents in August
sorry trialing this is software that
analyzes rent account and highlights
those tennis could non-payment the
August test should provide an accurate
calculation of what efficiencies we
could derive from deploying rain thereby
allowing income offices the time
necessary to focus on their more
challenging cases thank you and thank
you very much counselor a flat montfort
competitive response and the policies
I'm referring to has those to do with
financial inclusion those to do with
getting people into work new employment
policies wants to do with ensuring our
town centers have got jobs in them and
so on so forth so and I'd be interested
to follow this up but I don't have an
immediate question now chair but I hope
y'all follow this up at a later date
thank you very much Thank You councillor
eben if you'd like to move on for Thank
You chair this is my last question in
this section we have a we receive a
disabled facilities grant from
government and that's the performance
reporting is made at PS 0 for in the
butt
it's reporting report each year we have
problems in spending that report and
despite it changes over the last year in
terms of how people can of the threshold
for which people can apply for a grant
less has been spent this year than last
year in percentage terms my question is
why has the percentage of the total
grant spent not increased and what else
has been done to improve this Thank You
chair Council of flapman thank you for
your question can't sleep burn in
2018-19 263,000 553 was spent on the DFG
s who rose to three hundred and forty
eight thousand 105 in 2019 20 this is a
considerable improvement and although
the spend looks lower the total
available spend on the performances on
the performance report includes the
under spend from pre the previous year
the actual amount we had to spend from
the government grants in 23 1920 was
four hundred and forty thousand 100
based on the spend of three hundred and
forty-eight thousand one hundred and
five this equates to 79 percent spend as
members are aware a new regulatory
reform order policy was introduced in
December 2019 which allows the council
to offer DF G's more flexibly this
includes increasing the threshold for
non means-tested grants and the
introduction of other grants such as
support to facilitate a move to a more
appropriate home the home improvement
agency contract is due to end in
November this year and officers are
working hard to develop a new model with
Suffolk partners which will ensure
continuous improvement in the service
and enable more debt G's to be granted
thank you come thank you very much for
your response councillor flapman
I think perhaps that could be made much
clearer in that report because it's
extremely unclear and you'll risk your
responses much clearer than
what's what's dated at that point in the
report also I would could I please ask
that the if the the points that have
you've made with regards to further
improvements in order to get that grant
spent I circulated to all members please
because it's a subject that is really
close to lots of members hearts and we
know that there are people in our
communities that could really benefit
from the disabled facilities grants get
that money out there and working for
them
Thank You chair yes I totally agree and
every parish council meeting I go to I
emphasize the fact that this is
available to you know and to please
please put your applications forward and
I'm sure all members do this I do - yes
yeah and yes we will put that clearer
for all members thank you thank you very
much Thank You chair Thank You
councillor flapman and council ribbon
councillor Whalum you have a question
for councillor burned Thank You chair
can I can I first ask is a fairly
complicated question it will possibly
have a long answer can we be can we be
given sent by email the answers to the
questions that we are we are asking
rather than we have to make notes as I
go along yes of course thank you so in
the four years 2016-17 to 2019 28
neighborhood plans have been adopted
whilst it is difficult to set targets
for neighborhood plans in the
performance report SPO 304 no.5 clearly
show that more needs to be done to
encourage and support parishes to
prepare neighborhood plans publication
of the joint local plan may well prompt
parishes with neighborhood plans to
review their plans and some may need
significant revision staff presently
imposed have given excellent support
supporting neighborhood plan working
groups but new incentives and additional
support will be needed to assist the
eight parishes to update their plans and
encourage and support many more through
the process
what proposals do you have for
supporting for providing more support to
parishes
have neighborhood plans in need of
review and working groups which may need
extra support to complete their plans
and how will you provide encouragement
to parishes which despite a desire to
have a neighborhood plan have not yet
started work on their plans Thank You
councillor Byrne yes thank you
Thank You councillor Willem your
question starts with an assumption and
sort of paraphrasing it it says that
clearly more need to do encourage which
I think is probably a wider debate than
we can have now but I'm happy to have a
conversation about it outside the
meeting on your substantive point I'm
pleased that you consider the support
that the team have provided two groups
so far has been excellent I do too
alongside our neighborhood plans officer
we also have colleagues within the net
planning policy team available to
support and we'll be drawing colleagues
from the development management service
further into discussions with groups
given their role in using neighbourhood
plans to inform decision taking as well
as this it should also be noted that the
team undertake internal consultation
with a number of other teams across the
council when a neighborhood plan group
approaches with a pre regulation 14 plan
ultimately if a neighborhood group needs
to undertake a review which is an
entirely normal part and maintaining an
up-to-date neighborhood plan it is their
responsibility to do so and we will help
guide them through the process
essentially they need to review their
evidence and the emerging local and
national policy and we can then guide
them on the relevant stages they need to
go
through and offer advice at the
appropriate times as we currently do at
the moment encouragement for others to
commence work on neighborhood plans is
likely the most is likely to be most
effective coming from those who have
already undertaken a plan so we will put
measures in place to facilitate
conversations between those who have a
desire for a plan and those who already
have one does that help to answer your
question I'm very happy to discuss it
further with you as I say outside the
meeting then we'll see if we can devise
something that incorporates your views
on the on the subject as well cancel
well um do you have a follow-up question
um okay let's just say thank you for the
answer I just wonder whether there is a
role for for-ward members a greater
runners as we go through this stage of
having the joint local plan and I
certainly have a desire for four
parishes to come forward with
neighborhood plans and I wonder if
cancer the Bern feels that there is a
greater role that ward members can play
in in persuading and help reaches
through this through this phase well yes
my mmm I must admit that my assumption
is that Ward members will be very
significantly evolved with with any
group that is either helping to create a
plan a neighborhood plan or has already
started work on one I know that I have
in my ward those parishes that have
expressed an interest in in carrying in
carrying out the work here to
neighborhood plan I'm doing as much as I
can to help help them in that enterprise
there may be more help that we as a
council can give
councilors award members in order to you
know in order to carry out that help and
I can certainly look into that Thank You
councillor Byrne
now moving on to mid Suffolk item seven
and Baber item 6 which is matters
referred by the overview and scrutiny or
the joint order and standards committees
and can ask the governance officer to
report Thank You chair there were no
matters of a third thank you very much
mid Suffolk item 8 and Baber item 9 is
the forthcoming decisions list do any
cabinet members for Baber
or mid Suffolk have any comments no
thank you
so we now move on to the substantive
item for this simultaneous cabinet
meeting mid Suffolk item 9 and Baber
item 8 is mca / 1961 and Weber is BCA /
19 / 49 and this is the quarter for
performance outcome reporting so cabinet
members you have before you the
performance report and appendices for a
quarter four for the current year the
report recommends that the information
contained within and the appendices be
agreed as reflecting the council's
performance and you identify any
priority areas for further action
overall performance in management of
fly-tipping has improved with reduction
in incidents and an increase in
enforcement actions as well as a hundred
percent of clearances being completed
within 48 hours for kurta for cabinet
recommendations to agree that report and
appendices added adequately reflect the
council performance for quarter four and
the support of the service areas in
completing the performance report whilst
working under challenging circumstances
I would like to thank you all for your
continued hard work and support that you
have undertaken it in conjunction with
your assistant directors reviewing and
updates to ensure that the information
captured is focused in the outcomes and
in particular our priorities I would
therefore like to propose the
recommendations and would look for a
seconder Thank You councillor Julie
Flatman I'm happy to second chair thank
you very much and if I now hand over to
councillor Ward who will introduce the
paper paper Thank You castle Mori and I
would like to invite the bailer cabinet
member for customers digital
transformation and improvement to
introduce this report please Thank You
chair and absolutely I'll mirror the
previous comments by councillor Morley
again we just like to give thanks for
the support again of the service areas
in completing the performance report
again and I'm sure that all cabinet
members will will extend their gratitude
as well for the work that's been
undertaken under such challenging
circumstances I'm not sure if councillor
Molly mentioned it but there is an error
under the environment comment decay to
see pro4 should read 80 out of 81
fly-tipping incidents are cleared within
48 hours but other than that I concur
and support a seconder for the
recommendation as shown in 3.1 the chair
thank you
please grab a seconder from paper I'm
happy the second that councillor Davis
Thank You councillor Davis so first of
all we're going to take questions from
mid Suffolk members and then now we'll
take questions from Babel members so
again each of your names in alphabetical
order councillor Brewster do you have
any questions I think you might be muted
councillor sorry I apologize and now I
have no madam chair Thank You councillor
Byrne no not at the moment Thank You
councillor Plaquemine no chair not at
the moment
councillor Fleming not at this point
Thank You Chancellor councillor Gould no
thanks
Chancellor white it thank you
now move on to questions from Weber
members councillor Aarthi no questions
just one little comment I think when you
did your introduction you mentioned that
this was for the current year it's
obviously last year yes my apologies
Thank You councillor Busby no thanks
councillor Davis Thank You councillor
Holt no questions councillor Mele see no
questions councillor ozpin no questions
thank you madam chairman councillor
Parker no questions Jen councillor Ward
no questions Thank You Jay
if there's any other non cabinet members
who would like to speak with the
indicating the chat function thank you
no thank you
and now open up the item for debate
sorry chair I couldn't type fast enough
oh sorry counselor eben you have a
question Thank You chair council you
been speaking just two quick questions
please um I just wanted confirmation
that
I understood there was going to be a new
format for this for 2021 and I just
wanted if you could and also what form
that would take and secondly a question
with regards to the numbers on the
housing register which is page 56 HP
zero five and just wondered there was a
big fall q3 to q1 is going up again but
I just wondered if there were reasons
because there says no comments to follow
in the comments box
thank you very much chair Thank You
counsel I'm going to ask Sarah Wilcox to
reply to the first part of your question
especially with regard to the timings
for the changing of the format and then
I'll ask councillor flapman to respond
to your second part Sara Wilcox Thank
You chair and councillor burned for the
question yes as you correctly pointed
out we've always had an aspiration to to
refresh the indicators and particularly
the format that we provide our
aspiration is to have something for put
forward to you for quarter one
performance I have to be honest and say
that obviously we started that piece of
work before we went into lockdown and
all of the the pressures that have come
with providing services under these
circumstances have obviously come into
play I think what we would like to
provide for you is something that looks
different for quarter one but will be
underpinned by lots of the current
information that we currently provide to
you so that we don't withdraw any
information that is relevant to
performance moving forward and we use
that as an iterative process over the
comings particularly to get that report
right for you thank you very much Sarah
councillor Flaman would you like to
respond to council ribbons second point
chair yes yes can I'm sorry sorry off
I've minimized you to get I thought I'd
lost you and cancer reedburn can we get
back to you on that because I can't I I
don't actually know without I don't know
if an office there is a failure but I
don't have Gavin's in in the room is
there an officer who can answer that
question no thank canceller even we'll
get back to you on that yes that's gone
I just I just wondered if I hadn't asked
to earlier counts chair because I I
wondered if or the comments might might
come in at the last minute as it were
for that so thank you very much I'll
wait to hear thank you can I just check
that the officers captured that part of
the question correct yes chair I have
that written down lovely thank you very
much thank you
okay so now I'm going to open up this
item for debate so again I'm going to go
through a roll call councillor Brewster
I have no comments at the moment madam
chair Thank You councillor burn No thank
you madam chair councillor flapman no
thank you chair councillor fleming thank
you I just have a comment on the just
like to mention in appendix G I know
that anyone's you know looked through
these in that much detail but
performance measure W so8 which refers
to the amount of residual waste tell us
what page that is can Suleiman is
appendix page 8 of appendix G the
performance measure for waste is a new
measure and we don't yet have a target
and I just wanted to mention that I will
be working on coming up with a proper
target so that next time we get this
report there will be one there
and what I would like it to reflect is
the fact that we're trying to reduce the
amount of household waste generated I'm
on a in a per person or per household
basis this won't be a target where you
know the more we send the better it will
be something deflects objective to
reduce waste overall excellent thank you
very much councillor Fleming councillor
gold nothing for me at the moment thanks
searcher
Thank You councillor Whitehead nothing
for myself but looking at the
conversation box it appears that Castle
field has a question okay Thank You
councillor field we're in the debate
part now but did you have a question
that you could I did Oh point of the
debates and was waiting for that it
really obviously this report is always
very detailed and it's tempting to go
through each each line item almost which
would take us for a year I was just
looking at particularly building
services I noticed a corporate manager
is down as vacant that's not just an
insult it's a status of the job and it
says narrative to follow looking down
the various job percentages completed in
time the numbers look really low which
sort of questions is there just a an
enormous management problem there that
we just aren't getting things done all
the targets being set in a way that's
impossibly ambitious you know what is
the real story because it doesn't look
good with things like number of jobs
completed on time three days 37 percent
so we get one in three down in the time
we estimate that was called a four but I
don't think it changes you know why goes
up and down but there's no clear
statement you could make that oh it's
all down to covet 19 or something it
seems to be poor all through the year
okay okay thank you cancel field I think
what we'll do is we'll take that
question offline and come back to you
okay okay thank you
probably more propia to have it more
detailed discussion offline good so now
moving on to debate for Weber
councilmembers cancer Aarthi no thank
you no all fine Thank You councillor
Busby no thanks counsel Davis no all
good thanks
councillor Holt councillor Merle VC no
all good thank you
cancer Osborn no man chairing all
looking good throughout all the service
indicators thank you Thank You
councillor Parker nothing to debunk Jeff
thank you very much everybody
I'll now ask the government's officers
to the Rose yes councillor Ward you
didn't call me oh my apologies
councillor Ward I'm really sorry I just
have a couple of points I would like to
make if that's all right and the first
they're both concerned appendix G on on
waste services the first one relates to
ws6 and WS o 7 which are on the Baber
agenda page 64 I note that the
percentage of bins collected is running
roughly 99.9 percent which is excellent
and has been for for all of the past
couple of years which shows that the
service despite various hiccups is still
running essentially well but I find that
that doesn't kind of correlate with wso
7 the customer satisfaction levels
around about that the mid-80s I'm just
wondering what on earth we can
do to improve customer satisfaction in
addition beyond what we're doing already
and which is providing an excellent
collection service so I just find those
numbers don't really earn tally with one
another which is a bit disappointing
the other point I'd like to make is on
dealing page 63 on the Baber
agenda wso for the number of garden
waste subscribers this service continues
to attract more and more subscribers
every year it is clear it's an
incredibly popular service and about a
pound a week is proving to be not just
popular but excellent value for money
and it's it's clear it's a progressive
service and that only those people who
who need it and can afford it have to
pay for it and are willing to pay for it
it's a service that's therefore not
subsidized subsidized by the less
well-off members of our community and
frankly it baffles me that the greens
would wish to make this a free service
it's perfectly were as it is
Thank You Jay Thank You councillor Ward
on I apologize profusely for missing you
off obviously my brain was going faster
than my my reading was thank you I will
now ask the governance officer to
conduct the roll call vote Thank You
chair
we'll begin with mid Suffolk councillors
if I could ask you to say for against or
abstain the councillor Gerard Brewster
for councillor David Byrne for
councillor Julie fat man for councillor
Jessica Fleming for councillor Peter
Gould for councillor Susie Morley for
counselor John Whitehead for kinky
that's unanimous
and now for the Baber members councillor
Clive our fee for councillor Dave Busby
case
councillor Michael Holt war council
Elizabeth mell vc4 councillor John
Osborne for counselor Lee Parker before
and councillor John Ward for again
that's unanimous thank you thank you
very much so this meeting of the mid
Suffolk cabinet is now closed please
could all mid Suffolk members leave the
meeting and are hand over the chair to
the beba leader councillor John Ward the
next two items are for favour only
therefore only Bailey cabinet members
will be able to debate and vote on these
items the first of the two bay bar item
9b CA 1950 the community infrastructure
levy SIL expenditure program for June
2020 and I'll now invite the beba
cabinet member for planning to introduce
the report thanks John
okay so these are probably the first and
substantive decisions of the meeting
today I wanted to first of all thank
Christine Thurlow and her team for the
range of documents that you have before
you you'll notice that there's a high
level of detail probably more than you
actually need for your decision today
but you'll remember that we do this
reporting in line with the SIL calendar
so that you are aware of everything
that's going on so you've got the the
cabinet report got the SIL expenditure
program which is the new name for what
was the business plan that's at Appendix
A and you've got the test technical
assessments for the individual bids
appendix B the program also contains an
update on progress on decisions in 1 2 3
& 4 so those are all of the previous
rounds together with a list of the
emerging projects for SIL beads in
Appendix A section C that's another
change that's been made as a result of
the recent SIL expenditure frame
a review that's taken player that we
review cellphone work some things we
have to review because we're told to and
other things we review as a matter of
course there are three bits within the
recommendations for you to society today
now these are not bids in be drowned
five these are carried forward bids and
I would say just a little bit about each
one of them the first one is in Sudbury
accent Peters now you're aware of this
project it aims to improve the important
community building in the center of
Sudbury by rejuvenating the building to
form a cultural hub it's pivotal in
terms of the community in Sudbury and
the visioning and place shaping work
which is currently being undertaken
collaboratively within the town and I'm
sure all of you that attended the
exhibition they're familiar with the
facility the project will provide new
toilets baby changing facilities
wheelchair accessible facilities an
upgraded kitchen within the west end of
the church and the construction of a
mezzanine gallery with disabled lift
access and that project has a total
value of two and a half million pounds
much of which has already been secured
with the remaining Heritage Lottery bid
needing to be submitted by the 1st of
June 2020 as part of that submission
it's necessary to be able to demonstrate
that all the other funding has been
secured and that's the reason for the
urgency behind the determination of this
bid this morning the Planning Commission
listed building consent has been granted
for the work and the formal decisions
were issued in May of this year so the
recommendation for you there is to
approve the sill bid for seventy five
thousand two hundred and eighty eight
pan from the ring-fenced fund and sixty
two thousand four hundred and sixty one
thirteen from the Heritage sorry
and I the total bid of seventy five to
eight eight and from the ring-fenced
fund for Sudbury 62 46 113 and from the
local infrastructure fund twelve
thousand eight hundred and twenty six
eighty seven totaling seventy five to
eight eight the next one is is Newton
the recreation ground
it's a bid for a children's play area
and multi-use games area and mugga the
bid has been reviewed since the original
submission to address issues of costings
and scope and is now accompanied by
three quotes which we require to meet
the validation requirements planning
permission has been granted and unspent
section 106 monies are also being used
towards the scheme seven thousand one
hundred and three pounds has been
identified to go towards the project
costs and the parish councils
neighbourhood Silla fund will contribute
twenty thousand pounds they've secured a
twenty five thousand pound grant from
the communities team and the request for
SIL monies which was originally one
hundred and twenty five thousand pounds
has been able to be reduced to eighty
seven thousand eight hundred and ninety
one pound ninety so that's the amount of
the bid that you're being asked to
approve this morning and that will come
from the local infrastructure fund the
last one the third is in charge with and
I'm particularly pleased to report this
to you because I was Charles Worth's
councillor for 28 years up until the
boundary review last year and this was
something that was that was first mooted
probably about six six months twelve
months before before the elections last
May so I was aware of the project and
how it was progressing it's a fairly
unique project really it relates to
infrastructure improvements at the
church in order to provide enhanced
community usage of the church as the
existing village hall cannot fulfill the
need so they've got a small
I suppose it's it's actually a large
shade I was going to say a small haul
it's a bit like a shed but it's actually
really it's a large shed and looks at
the church involved the provision of a
toilet kitchen storage area restoration
works - the organ and its repositioning
on an elevated platform a sort of a
gallery and allows the opportunity to
maximize usable for all space by the
community with it with the new toilet
and kitchen the church provides the only
village venue for community events the
larger community events that can't can't
be accommodated in the hall and the
proposed scheme of works and the overall
project will allow the use to be
expanded and intensified together with a
widening of usage to include educational
historical and learning opportunities so
I think it's probably important to
mention since this is quite unique and
it is a church and you're aware I'm sure
of the provisions within our framework
none of the requested SIL monies would
be used for the restoration or the
repair of the church or the organ okay
because that would be classed as a
repair under the sill expenditure
framework and and we are not able to
provide funding for that the the bid
that you've got in front of you is for
the rooms it's a bid for one hundred and
thirty six thousand two hundred and
forty four pounds which would come from
the local infrastructure fund again as
for Newton so all three bids have been
the subject of much hard work by the
community and by Christine's team these
are all carried for bids this of course
is not a report on on bid round five
these bits that have come forward over a
period of time they're subject to the
provisions that were in place at the
time we made that decision that the new
provisions won't apply to the old bids
so this comes to be judged under our old
framework provisions the the bids have
been particular
the important in terms of the way that
communities have have put together
collaborative funding arrangements some
pizzas in Sudbury I think there are 21
different from funding streams including
sill and and other monies from Baber
which have all had to come together to
make the project happen all three bids
total more individually than the project
limitation of 75,000 pounds under the
new framework but as I said these
thought to be judged under our old
framework which didn't have such a
restriction so the recommendations in
front of you are three point one and
three point two and just to summarize
the figures that's eighty-seven thousand
eight hundred ninety one pounds and
ninety two the Newton project for the
play area a hundred and thirty six
thousand two hundred and forty four
pounds two shells worth four works to
the church and seventy-five thousand two
hundred and eighty eight to Sudbury
again four works to the church I propose
those thank you chairman Thank You
councillor Aarthi may I have a seconder
please councillor mal vzl second Thank
You council ml BC right are there any
questions from favorite members firstly
councillor Aarthi um no I just presented
the report I think that's what I thought
yeah good thank you
councillor Busby you have a couple on
the All Saints Church and chills worth
five have they considered spending the
money on upgrading the floor of the
village hall that's a really good
question I I may just defer to Christine
in a minute because she she undertook a
lot of the conversations with them but
from my knowledge of the village over a
number of years the the this project and
the village hall are aiming at
completely different users so the
village hall is particularly well used
by a quilting group they love it
they've got a flat floor
not in particularly good condition but
they've got a flat floor and and they
can lay their tables out and it's cheap
when it comes to a variety of other uses
I don't know if you know the hall but
it's it's got a very low ceiling it's
it's got very little in the way of car
parking it's it's quite challenged in
terms of uses of village hall I don't
know if Christine wants to add anything
to that it was Christine I think who had
all of the conversations with Chelsea
thank you yes we did have a meeting with
the community we did consider whether we
could put funds in in order to improve
the floor which is quite unstable and
only capable of being used by quilters
who apparently walk on the floor to a
table and then it's a very center the
experience that they have because the
floor is so unstable but the view of the
community were that if they improved the
floor then they would have to improve
the walls then they would have to
improve the roof and really it would be
like a rebuilding of that facility it's
about a hundred years old and really the
only capable of just enough maintenance
in order to keep its use going
if the quilters didn't use the facility
I dare not very much whether it would be
suitable for anybody else to use in the
community which is why they decided to
come together and produce a project
which would actually give them
communities in the chat okay so if if
it's only the quilters to be using the
village hall presumably they'll be able
to use the upgraded church once it's
been done in which case a village hall
has no purpose whatsoever african the
community considered knocking it down
and putting a house there and generating
the funds that way I don't know the
answer to that I don't know if Christine
does but before Christine answers and
while she's got a bit of time to think
about an answer I would say that
of these rural churches in small
villages our existing historic buildings
which have have ended up being less well
used than they they were once perhaps
they provide a wonderful space and as I
understand it the sort of uses that
they're hoping to attract to the village
bearing in mind that they already have
an attraction being chels with open
gardens which is a big event every year
but the the type of events that they're
hoping to attract to the village would
not fit into the village hall at all so
I'm guessing that the village hall will
carry on with its limited use for the
time being and I'm guessing that when
the project at the church is completed
then they will probably look at the
future of the village hall yes it may
well be that that they might be able to
to do something there okay thank you I
was going to invite Christine's sorry
customer yes Christine you want to have
any response to castle Busby please yes
thank you so when we have the meeting
with the community we had the group that
are responsible for looking after the
maintenance of the village hall in with
that as a conjoined project these works
that they're doing to the Church of
phase 2 phase 1 involve new lighting and
new heating at the church so what would
ultimately end what the community would
have at the end of this is a much
enhanced community space I didn't form
the impression that the the quilters
wouldn't be allowed to to come to the
church I rather form the impression that
they they might because it's really only
that usage by the quilters
that is actually paying for the
maintenance of the village hall in terms
of who owns the village hall I don't
believe it's the community I think it's
a third party and there may have been a
change in family membership in respect
of owners so I can't give you a
categoric sort of guarantee that the use
of that building by the quilters will
continue I think it is probably likely
in fact everything will will merge
together at the church but that's really
for the okay but it's it it just seems
to me that the there is a source of
funds readily available there even
though it may be in the hands of a third
party and we're spending our thousand
pounds when potentially there could be a
hundred thousand pounds available for
the sale of the plot the village hall
[Music]
week or Krishna I'm not sure we can take
that into consideration can we when when
determining silk still payment Awards
certainly that is something that was not
offered as part of this Syl bit but the
Silpat that has been been made is not a
hundred percent still bid although we
are we are ending three figures 136,000
on this SIL front the actual total cost
of the work is 267 so they have raised
quite a lot of funds locally in order to
support this SIL bid going forward I
don't understand in enough detail the
tenure of the village hall enable to be
able to answer whether that money would
be available to the community should the
site be or should the building be
demolished and the site redeveloped it
it may go back to the
the ownership of the family concerned
but that sits prepped to determination
of the sill bid before you today
Thank You Christine okay so how much if
chills worth raised in terms of sill
funding and roughly how many people are
there in chills with cancer Arthi whilst
councillor Busby was asking that
question I am just accessing the exocomp
pages can you still hear me yeah yeah
I'm doing lots of things on the computer
at the moment so if I just have a look
at the shells worth I'm guessing it
won't be very much that we'll have a
look
shells worth it looks as though they're
they have nothing in the pot at the
moment but there is a potential in other
words an expected amount from existing
permissions of 58,000 pounds in total a
councillor Busby the population mid-2012
was 126 okay like an awful lot of money
that we're spending out of sill for a
comparatively small village when there
are potentially other funds available I
guess they may have looked at that I
would like to think they would have done
but I guess I'll flood this to death can
I just can I know Christine please do i
just remind members that the amount of
the still bed being asked for although
it is a hundred and thirty six thousand
two hundred and forty four pounds the
total cost of the sill bed was two
hundred and sixty three thousand three
hundred and seventy pounds so the
remainder of the money has been raised
either by getting external fun they have
had a twenty five thousand pound
communities grant and I believe they
have also obtained in the order of sixty
six thousand from memory from their Open
Gardens events that they have in Chelse
worth which are very popular I mean it
may not even be happening this year but
in previous years it is something that
coach it's come to in terms of you know
wanting to go around the garden so they
have done quite a lot in terms of
getting together in order to support
this
I think just the final answer to your
question
hopefully day with regard to the monies
that have been raised through SIL in
villages it obviously was never our
intention that the only facilities that
could bid would be ones in villages
where contributions had already exceeded
the bid amount it was provide for
smaller rural areas which in all honesty
are never going to have the level of
development required to generate the
amounts of money and a lot of that has
gone towards things like village halls
if you remember preston samara village
hall had a bid in for an extension and
everything in the case of chels worth I
don't think it would be possible to
actually repair the village hall to
bring it up to modern standards
notwithstanding what Christine has said
about the ownership of the land which
would also be an issue but the other
thing is that the amount of money they
would be seeking were they hoping to
replace the village hall with the new
building would be far in excess of the
amount that they're hoping to secure in
this way to turn the church into a
usable community facility so there are
two ways of looking at it one way of
looking at it is the way that you're
looking at it would you saying this is a
lot of money the other way of looking at
it is probably to say this is a lot less
money than we would we would have in
front of us if an alternative provision
for a community facility was being
proposed Thank You councillor Aarthi
castle Busby is that all right does that
answer your question sufficiently can we
move on please yeah yeah I guess it does
thank you okay thank you
next on the list of questions councillor
Davis no thank you
castle a halt no fine Thank You
councillor lvc no thank you
Castle Osbourne no questions Thank You
mr. chairman councillor Parker
well obviously optically has an interest
but no particular questions at this time
jet thank you do any other members
present have any questions no right then
we'll move on to the debate then I'll
open this up for debate for Babel
members moving again through through
everyone in turn counselor Aarthi I know
you've introduced the paper and you've
answered several questions do you have
anything else you wish to contribute to
the debate well I wanted to propose the
recommendations as well I think I did
say that yeah if I can put a proposal
that we accept these beats as I as I
said that's eighty-seven thousand eight
hundred and ninety one for the Newton
project a hundred and thirty six 244 for
Charles worth and seventy-five thousand
two hundred and eighty-eight split
between the two funds four separate
thank you Thanks councillor Busby is
there anything else you wish to say
about these items and no thanks castle
Davis no I'm all good thank you
councillor halt no fine thank you castle
MOV C thank you
counselor Osbourne yeah if I could just
make a comment please mr. chairman
councillor Arthur has already referred
to it but the some Peters project is an
excellent project and it's fits in with
both the baby and the Town Council's
vision for Sudbury and also with the
strong possibility of the loss of the
Delfy Community Center coming forward
then it will be greatly needed in
Sudbury Thank You mr. chairman Thank You
councillor castle Parker thinking chair
I too would just like to put a comment
in I've just endorse what councillor
Aarthi said that is outset really and so
far as I would like to give thanks to
Christine and also the sill team and
also the grants team as well so speaking
in respect has Ward member of Newton
it's been an absolutely fantastic effort
that that the whole team have have
helped and assisted and I'd also like to
commend Newton as well in the way that
they've got about putting this bid
together and their approach they've been
very bold and they have contributed a
significant sum of their own money and
in that respect I believe that they've
led the way in setting an example for
the district in in terms of reinvesting
that SIL that's still money that they've
received into something that he's going
to be really beneficial for not just the
residents of Newton but the community of
Ballmer at large so thank each other
Thank You counsel Parker well I just
like to say that these are three
excellent bits and and I support them
wholeheartedly and I'd particularly like
to concur with Castle Osborne regarding
some Peters this is so essential for our
vision for Sudbury the the Town
Council's vision for Sudbury and the
churches Conservation Trust has put
together a very ambitious but exciting
plan for the the the renovation of the
church they've being able to put
together grants and funding from a
number of sources including ourselves at
Baber and have now put in a very strong
bid to the Heritage Lottery Fund for
remaining funding it's fully supported
by Baber
by the tank
and also the Friends of some Peters this
is a project that we really do want to
see succeed because as I said it's going
to be excellent for Sudbury right I'll
now move and ask the the governance
officer to conduct the the roll call for
the vote unless there are the-- so I
just saw your comment you'd like to
comment before the vote got a request
really well um it's really a question
that I was expecting to be asked but
wasn't asked and I was I was just going
to mention the fact that big round five
has now closed at the time the paper
report was was written the drought was
still open and I thought it might be
useful if Christine could just update us
on the progress with be drowned five
Christine are you able to do that please
yes thank you so the big round has
closed we're at the point where we're
acknowledging it's going forward there
have been new five new bids submitted in
fact of bid round five there is a health
bid in Hadley there are two bids in
Lavenham one in Holbrooke and one in
Kersey and work pretty much starts now
in respect of bringing the matters that
we need to consider together in order to
bring a report before you which would
like be likely to be in September this
year thank you thank you Christina
Kathy do you wish to say anything more
no thanks for that Kristen I just
thought it would be useful if you were
all aware of the fact although we've had
this coronavirus issue that work is
continuing
we had bids come in during bid round 5
which as Christine says are going to be
considered she didn't mention the amount
of those bids but I understand together
they are probably just over 150 pounds
worth the last question I could ask
Christine
is that she could just confirm the
amount of money that we've we've now got
collected and available I think it's
gone up very slightly since the paper
was written and it's probably sitting at
about is it about two and a half million
Christine yes it is okay thanks yeah
I've proposed it John I don't think it's
been second to jail Casa Loma BC second
is it great thanks
so I'll now ask the governor's officer
to conduct the roll call vote please
Thank You chair you could alt mr.
chairman could I could I just don't
terrifying I'm something please before
we go to the vote I was sorry counsel
Osborn yes I just saw your conversation
is it okay for me to vote on this one I
did you Claire just a non-pecuniary but
I just want to clarify that I am okay in
voting on the this one especially the
insolent features one German it's it's a
mere you'll hear the monitoring officer
and yes it's absolutely fine for
councillor Osborn to their core
non-pecuniary interest Thank You Emily
thank you
can we now move to the vote please Thank
You chair so if you could answer for
against or abstain councillor Clyde our
fee for councillor Dave Busby all
councillor Derrick Davis or councillor
Michael Holt or counsel Elizabeth mal VC
for councillor channels form for
councillor Lee Parker
I've withdrawn from the vote that's
abstain and counselor John Ward for
Thank You chair that's seven four and
one abstain Thank You fair right moving
on we're now considering exclusion of
the public including the press that's to
consider whether pursuant to part one of
schedule 12 a of the local government
back to 1972 the public should be
excluded from the meeting for the
business specified below on the grounds
that if the public were present during
this item it is likely that there would
be a disclosure to them of exempt
information as indicated against the
item the author of the report proposed
to because it in part two of the agenda
are satisfied that the public interest
in maintaining the exception outweighs
the public interest in disclosing the
information may have a proposer please
counsel I'll propose thank you and a
seconder yeah I will
Dave must be canceled buzz me up I will
now ask the government's officer to
conduct the roll call vote you chair
once again it's four against or abstain
councillor Clive our fee for councillor
Dave Busby
councillor Derrick Davis or councillor
Michael Holt for councillor Elizabeth
now fees for counselor John Osborne for
council Lee Parker for and councillor
John Ward for Thank You chair that's
unanimous thank you
right
[Music]
you
you